es posible que a usted oa alguien que
conoce le hayan diagnosticado un
problema de salud mental también
conocido como trastorno psiquiátrico
este vídeo le ayudará a comprender cómo
funciona el cerebro en la salud mental y
cómo los problemas pueden causar
enfermedades mentales la salud mental es
su capacidad de manejar o sobrellevar el
estrés y de disfrutar de la vida diaria
incluye la forma en la que se siente
piensa actúa y se relaciona con los
demás
los científicos estudian como ciertas
áreas del cerebro afectan la salud
mental
por ejemplo el área del miedo del
cerebro llamada la amígdala le ayuda a
evitar cosas perjudiciales y a escapar
del peligro además la amígdala funciona
con la corteza prefrontal para controlar
su respuesta a eventos temerosos y
estresantes la corteza prefrontal
también ayuda a tomar decisiones
resolver problemas y recordar memorias
la corteza cingulada anterior le ayuda a
enfocarse en las tareas y a controlar
las emociones
el hipocampo ayuda a crear y almacenar
nuevos recuerdos
las unidades de trabajo del cerebro son
células llamadas neuronas también
conocidas como células cerebrales las
neuronas se pasan mensajes entre sí a
través de impulsos eléctricos los
impulsos pasan a lo largo de una parte
de la neurona llamada axón
aquí puede ver más de cerca como un
mensaje pasa de una neurona a la otra al
extremo del axón el impulso hace que la
neurona libere mensajeros químicos
llamados neurotransmisores
estos mensajeros químicos se mueven a
través de un espacio diminuto llamado
espacio sináptico y se adhieren a otra
neurona esto desencadena la neurona que
produzca su propio impulso
de este modo los impulsos se esparcen a
través del cerebro los problemas con
este proceso pueden tener como resultado
trastornos cerebrales conocidos como
enfermedades mentales todas las causas
de enfermedades mentales no son
conocidas sin embargo una cantidad de
factores pueden contribuir con esto
algunos de estos factores son
antecedentes familiares de enfermedad
mental que pueden ser pasados de padres
a hijos a través de los genes eventos
estresantes o emocionales severos en su
vida o una lesión en la cabeza o
cerebral otros factores pueden incluir
problemas de salud como enfermedades
cardíacas
problemas con otras sustancias químicas
en el cuerpo llamadas hormonas abuso de
drogas y adicciones
y un desequilibrio de mensajeros
químicos en el cerebro
cuando hay un desequilibrio de
mensajeros químicos en el cerebro las
neuronas pueden tener problemas para
pasar mensajes entre ellas el mensajero
químico más común es el glutamato
aumenta la posibilidad de que se forme
un impulso en otras neuronas
las personas con enfermedades mentales
como autismo trastorno obsesivo
compulsivo esquizofrenia enfermedad de
alzheimer y depresión pueden tener
problemas para fabricar o utilizar el
glutamato la serotonina otro mensajero
químico ayuda a controlar el humor el
hambre y el sueño por ejemplo las
personas con depresión a menudo no
tienen suficiente serotonina la dopamina
ayuda a controlar el movimiento y está
involucrada con los sentimientos de
placer y adicción
los bajos niveles de dopamina o
problemas con la capacidad del cerebro
para utilizarla pueden estar vinculados
con la esquizofrenia el trastorno por
déficit de atención con hiperactividad o
tdh y otros trastornos
un estimado de 40 y 37 millones de
adultos en los eeuu tienen algún tipo de
enfermedad mental
las herramientas de investigación
modernas y la tecnología avanzada
permitirán que los científicos
comprendan mejor el cerebro y cómo
ocurren las enfermedades mentales si
tiene alguna pregunta sobre la salud
mental o cualquier medicamento que le
hayan recetado hable con su profesional
de la salud o médico es importante que
tome los medicamentos como se lo indique
su profesional de la salud o médico
cuente les sobre cualquier efecto
secundario que experimente